-Our first guest tonight
is a WWE superstar
and 16-time world champion
who you also know from films
such as "Trainwreck,"
"Blockers," and "Sisters."
He's currently starring in "F9,"
the ninth chapter
in "The Fast and the Furious
franchise,
which is in theaters
this Friday.
Let's take a look.
♪♪♪♪
-Sending a new pickup location
-[ Laughs ]
Please welcome back to the sho
John Cena.
How are you, John?
-Fantastic.
Just some zip lines,
midair collisions,
and knuckle sandwiches
in a bespoke tailor shop.
-Yeah.
-This is "F9."
-When you're on a zip line, th
last thing you're worried abou
is somebody crashing
into the side of you
and throwing you
through a glass window.
And yet there you were.
-Seth, that's the last thing
"you're" worried about.
[ Laughter ]
-You look -- First of all,
let me just note,
because I feel like it's alway
a mistake to overlook it.
You look as dapper as ever
as well-dressed guest
as we have on the show.
-I can see
that you're still blind.
[ Laughter ]
-I also want to say this i
one of those movies,
it's very exciting
because this is the kind of film
that I think people
love to see in a theater.
It comes out on Friday.
Have you heard from people
who have seen it yet
or people who are excited
to go see it?
-Yeah, and honestly,
it's been really thrilling
You know, we wanted to release
this film in April
before COVID hit,
and then the world changed
So Universal chose to wait
and now, we're in a position
where people can safely go
and enjoy it,
and all the journalists
that I've talked to are like
"Man, I saw this in the theater,
and it reminded me of how much
I love to go see movies."
And it really is important
to hear that.
It really is special
because "Fast"
is a great movie experience.
It does crazy, wacky stuff
as you saw in the action.
There's a really cool narrativ
in there.
You don't have to watch
the previous installments.
You can just sit down and have
fun and escape for a little bi
and go to a theater
and remember the sensation
that we so long for and we miss.
And I'm really proud
that "F9" is a vehicle
to get people back in a cinema
-It also must be nice,
even though you filmed it
two years ago and so you'r
sitting on this movie,
you must know the whole time
"Well, at least
when this is over,
people will still like thing
that are fast and furious.
Like, it wasn't like America was
going to grow out --
or the world, I should say
was going to grow out of
their taste for this franchise
-Well, it was also kind of
difficult because we dropped
the first trailer at
the Super Bowl two years ago
And it got the most views
of any trailer.
So excitement and expectatio
was there,
which means that
demand was there.
And then we just had
an 18-month stop down.
So it was really -- you know
you're anxious to see
if you can build that hype
and excitement again.
But it's -- The fans that ar
dedicated to this franchis
around the world
have just been awesome.
And everybody has, you know,
been patient with us.
And it's really awesome that
you know, it's finally upon us
and everybody can go enjoy it.
-You obviously are no stranger
to stunts
and doing your own stunts.
Was there anything in this fil
that impressed you
or sort of had you take a moment
to think,
"Oh, I've never seen
this before"?
-Oddly enough,
the "Fast" family.
Like, literally,
the get-togethers off camera
And that scene
at the end of every "Fast,
which is a barbecue and Coronas,
that's like
how it is off camera.
So it was really cool
to just hang out with people
that I guess
they just celebrated
their 20th anniversary
that I've grown up watchin
and be able to learn about the
as human beings.
It was really unique,
and I didn't think that
there was such a thing and it'
actually a "Fast" family.
It was pretty cool.
-You have talked on the show
before about your love of cars
Was there anything on this set
that you wish
you could have
taken home with you?
-Man, I saw them
wreck a $250,000 Jag.
That sucked.
That hurt my heart a lot.
I saw my first TVR, which yo
can't bring over to the U.S.
because of
the 25-year import rule.
I saw the brand-new Apollo
I saw "the" car,
the Lamborghini that they us
as a 25th anniversary Countach
like, the one
they paraded around.
There were so many,
so many great cars.
And I got to drive
a little bit too.
So, yeah, I've done
some social-media profiles
There's an Aston Martin
Vanquish S,
the brand-new Apollo,
and the Countach in the middle
Those were cars
that barely made the film,
and that right there,
literally all in,
is probably $3 million worth
of metal.
So "Fast" goes big
on everything, man.
-We're looking to get a new car.
How are these with --
Can these fit child seats?
-So, no.
-Okay.
-So, no. Yep.
So those three are out.
[ Laughter ]
Yep. Yep.
-You're also keeping busy
as always,
co-hosting the show "Wipeout."
We had your guest --
your co-host, I should say
Nicole on the show.
And have you ever wanted,
watching that show,
to give the actual
obstacle course a try?
-No. As a self-proclaimed
fall-down man
from my existence in WWE,
not a freaking chance.
-[ Laughs ]
-Like, just looking at
the course, its so spectacular
and everything is padded
and there's water everywhere
And Nicole is like,
"Man, I'd give this a run.
She had a broken foot
at the time.
I looked right at her, I said,
"You're crazy."
And then we watched contestant
go through.
And we cut the show together
to show, like, the best
because if we ran it
as a continuous loop,
some of the contestants were
on the course for 90 minutes
And, like, you fall once
and you get your mind shook.
And then you're shocked by
the cold water
and you get all muddy.
You really get exhausted.
So I really just like watching
I think that's
the best position for me.
-It must be --
I mean, the 90-minutes part,
watching the same person doe
seem a little rough.
But I can only imagine
how much fun it is to watch it
especially with
someone like Nicole.
-Oh, honestly,
it's a great show.
And Nicole is the perfect
personality for the show
because it's a lighthearte
show.
You know you're going to
mangle yourself
in the safest way possible
They want people
to exude character,
and our contestants
literally make the show.
So we just get to
kind of sit back
and be lighthearted with it.
It's not a show where it takes
the competition seriously.
It really -- We can tell jokes
We can have a good time.
And I think that's what's
a lot of the enjoyment
of watching it
as a viewer as well.
-Well, thank you for giving us
so much to watch,
and we're very excited
for the new film on Friday
And always a pleasure
to see you, John.
I really appreciate it.
-Man, it's great
to see you again.
I can't wait to be back ther
in studio with you.
I really look forward to
that time soon,
and thank you very much
for the time.